Speaker 1: Let's go next to David from
Philadelphia. David from Philadelphia. Welcome,
sir. What is on your mind today?
Speaker 4: How you doing,
David? I'm a longtime listener.
Speaker 1: Thank you. Great to hear from you.
Speaker 4: I think you're better
than better than pretty much every
other podcast or I think the Young Turks,
they're on a pedestal too much. You're very
pragmatic, which is why I listen to you.
Speaker 1: I appreciate all compliments.
Speaker 4: Okay. So something I want to bring
up because it does strike. It's a little bit
personal. I grew up with parents who both a
mother and stepfather who became MAGA. But
you were talking about how Jim Breuer would put
on that crappy comedy routine and everybody's
laughing hysterically just because he's making
jokes at the expense who they don't like.
I don't think they really find it funny.
Speaker 1: Oh, really? So let me just make sure
before you give me your commentary. What David's
referring to is we've played these clips from the
Reawaken America tour. It's like a right wing
religious anti-vaxx. It's almost like a revival
type thing. They do it in a circus tent sometimes
or a church tent. And Jim Breuer does these
routines where he jokes he like walks around what
he pretends to be like a parakeet or something.
I don't know. And he makes stupid faces. And in
the most recent one, he fell down on the ground,
kind of mocking DeMar Hamlin and the idea that
DeMar Hamlin actually suffered a cardiac arrest
from the COVID vaccine. And one of the things I
commented on is David is pointing out is people
in the audience are laughing hysterically
like they've never seen a comedy movie.
Like somehow this is funny to them. They must be
incredibly sheltered. You're saying? David They
don't really find it funny. They're pretending.
Speaker 4: I think they are trying to laugh at it.
They're forcing the laughter out of themselves.
And I'll explain why. This is why I brought up my
parents. I'll try to keep make this anecdote
as short as possible. Okay. Me and my mom,
back when we were closer, we watched this TV show
called Supernatural, the two brothers who go,
you know, travel across the country killing
demons and ghosts and all this stuff.
Well, one of the main characters, he had to, you
know, con a bunch of demons or lie to them or
something. And the other main character is like,
why are you going to lie to him? And then the
main character says, Well, that's how you become
president. And this was during Obama when Obama
was president. So this gets a laugh out of my
mother. Yep. Just because she thinks it's making
fun of Obama, right? Then the next week, the same
main character, he gets transported into a future
where everything is apocalyptic. And then you
see on the newspapers presidents Sarah Palin.
My mother is completely silent. Hmm. And
there's other anecdotes like this, but
this is the one that sticks out in my head
the most. They don't really think this stuff's
funny. They just want to they want to laugh.
Speaker 1: They want to they see themselves
as being team players by laughing at the stuff
that for political reasons, they think they're
supposed to be laughing at.
Speaker 4: Correct.
Speaker 1: Gotcha. It's a
perfectly plausible hypothesis.
Speaker 4: Yeah, but that's I've noticed
you've had two videos about Jim Breuer
doing that stupid bad comedy as well as.
GUTFELD And you're saying, like, this is
what this is what these right wingers find funny.
Speaker 1: You know, there's a lot you're actually
making me think. I actually wouldn't be surprised
if to some degree, a lot of these right wingers
don't actually understand comedy and satire at
all, whether it's left or right wing. And they're
really just taking social cues where they are
aware that Brewer is a comedian and they are sort
of like in the idea, this is supposed to be funny,
but they they they don't get his comedy and they
wouldn't get Chris Rock's comedy either. They just
don't get comedy. And they're just laughing based
on the social expectations that they identify.
Speaker 4: No, I think, yeah, there's that
actually reminds me of when what you were showing
me from Brewer. It's like you hear the obnoxious
voices he's making and you're you know that
this is supposed to be the funny part, right?
Like, I know that his obnoxious voices,
they're supposed to laugh at that. Yeah, they
laugh even harder because it's, you know, it's.
Speaker 1: They know that that's what sometimes,
you know, when you're supposed to clap. And so
you can know when you're supposed to laugh, too.
Yes, exactly. Interesting. Interesting.
I think I think there's a lot to what
you're saying, quite frankly.
Speaker 4: Thank you. Thank you.
Speaker 1: All right, David from
Philadelphia, thank you very much for
the call. I appreciate it. Let's go to Logan
from Seattle. Logan, welcome to the program.
Logan, welcome to the program. Logan from Seattle.
And last chance for Logan from Seattle.
Welcome to the program. No, Logan,
that is really too bad. And that was going to
have to be a short call anyway, because I'm at
the end of our time for today. We will take calls
again. I appreciate everybody that I was able
to speak to today. We'll take a quick break and
continue with the Friday show right after this.